70% of a bottle of Milagro Reposado, 40% of a bottle of Parrot Bay Coconut Rum, 30% of
a bottle of Hendrick's Gin, 10% of a bottle of Mr. Boston Blue Curacao, 1 bottle of Mr.
Boston Triple Sec, 40% of a bottle of Boll's Elderflower Liqueur, 1 liter bottle, 90% of
a bottle of Caravella Limoncello, half of a bottle of Grenadine, 25% of a bottle of
Meyer's Dark Rum, 2 bottles of Caravella Limoncello, 1 bottle of Pueblo Viejo, 1 bottle of Yave
Coconut Tequila, 60% of a bottle of Jim Beam, 50% of a bottle of Tito's, 90% of a bottle
of Wheatley's, half of a bottle of Parrot Bay White Rum, 1 bottle of Siete Mysterios
Mezcal, 10% of a bottle of Pueblo Viejo, 10% of a bottle of Eagle Rare, 40% of a bottle
of Blanton's, 40% of a bottle of Crown Royal, 60% of a bottle of Tankeray, 10% of a bottle
of Jack Daniel's, 90% of a bottle of Eagle Rare, 60% of a bottle of Milagros Silver,
50% of a bottle of Casamigos Blanco, 1 bottle of Grand Gala Orange Liqueur,
6 Pacificos, 13 Athletic Non-Alcoholic Brews, 7 Coors Lights, 17 Miller Lights,
12 Michelob Ultras, 16 Yinglings,
1 bottle of Pueblo Viejo, 1 bottle of Wheatley's Vodka,
1 bottle of Cream of Coconut, 4 bottles of Cream of Coconut,
2 bottles of Blue Agave Syrup, 1 bottle of Strawberry Puree,
1 Ginger Beer, 5 bottles of Charles de Fer Brut,
2 bottles of 30A Rose, 3.5 bottles of Carter's Lot Rose, 1 more bottle of Charles de Fer,
4.5 bottles of Watermelon Mixer, 4.5 bottles of Mojito, 1.5 bottles of Margarita,
7 bottles of Squealing Pig, 1 bottle of 30A Chardonnay,
4.5 bottles of Scarpetta Pinot Grigio, 4 bottles of Windstorm Chardonnay,
2 bottles of Jim Beam, 24 cans of Coors Light, 12 cans of Miller Light, 24 cans of Pacifico,
24 cans of Michelob Ultra, 24 cans of Yingling, 2 bottles of Meyer's Dark Rum,
2 bottles of Grey Goose 1 Liter, 2 bottles of Pueblo Viejo, 10% of a bottle of Peach Schnapps,
50% of a bottle of Aperol, 1 bottle of Mr. Boston Blue Curaçao, 75% of a bottle of
Michter's Straight Rye, 10% of a bottle of Rumple Mints, 2 bottles of Wheatleys,
2 bottles of Fireball, 1 bottle of Yave Coconut Tequila, 1 bottle of Crop Organic Cucumber Vodka,
1 bottle of Parrot Bay Coconut Rum, 1 bottle of Campesino Silver Rum, 1 bottle of Nocello,
1 bottle of Woodford, 1 bottle of Chambord,
60% of a bottle of Tia Maria Cold Brew Coffee Liqueur, 1 bottle of Parrot Bay White Rum,
1 bottle of Crop Organic Cucumber Vodka, 1 bottle of Woodford, 1 bottle of Crown Royal,
half of a bottle of Campesino Aged Rum,
1 bottle of Bowls Elderflower Liqueur, 1 liter bottle, 1 bottle of Woodford,
1 bottle of Blanton's,
1 liter bottle of Michter's,
12 Coors Lights, 6 Yinglings,
5 30A IPA Cans,
13 30A Rosé Gose Cans,
1 4-pack of High Rise Pineapple,
2 cans of High Rise Blueberry, 2 cans of High Rise Pineapple,
1 can of Red Bull Sugar Free,
4 4-packs of Mom Waters,
1 more 4-pack of Mom Waters,
16 Watermelon High Noons,
9 Pineapple High Rises,
2 Blueberry High Rises,
8 Red Bulls,
7 Mom Waters,
11 High Noon Watermelon,
3 High Noon Pineapple,
6 Red Bulls,
7 Red Bulls,
8 Red Bulls,
2 bottles of Gearbox,
1 bottle of Shaker Red Blend,
1 bottle of Canoe Ridge Merlot,
75% of a bottle of Windstorm Cabernet Sauvignon,
75% of a bottle of Canoe Ridge Merlot,